I think Teach for America is a wonderful
idea in our school for the first time
this year we have to Teach for America
teachers and i think it's a it's an
interesting concept and what what it
peels to me is that they are finding the
best and brightest young people out of
colleges to become part of this program
they may not have the the the time and
and and a depth of study and education
at by the time they begin teaching but
they are smart and energetic and and and
i think very determined to succeed
there is a very interesting program it
happens to be in Kansas City at the
university of missouri at kansas city
it's called the institute for urban
education the philosophy is that
teachers need to be prepared for the
inner city as in other words they need
they need to be they need to be like
specialists just like doctors when they
go to medical school will specialize in
a particular field that same concept is
used at this institute for urban
education so that the time a student
comes in as a freshman they are immersed
in schools that are in the urban core
and they are absolutely prepared over a
four-year period to be placed in an
inner-city school and I really think
this is a very novel idea for a couple
of reasons it sort of suggests that this
the environment and urban school is
unique and it also is unique in the
sense that these students are spending
much much more time in inner-city
schools so that over the four-year
period they will spend it at least
double the amount of time in actual
schools than in a traditional teacher
education program which i think is a
positive thing
you